priority number one serve others
priority number one
be obsessed with making an impact on the
end user gary
v was breaking it down he just said do
you think about the viewer
first or don't you
so i have a question for you podcast
listener how do you
experience continual growth on youtube
without the
fake it till you make it strategy you
know what i'm talking about right
where you see these influencers with
hundreds of thousands of views
or people on instagram with hundreds of
thousands of followers and three likes
on their photos
you know the fake it till you make it
strategy well in today's episode shawn's
gonna get a little spicy we're going all
in
on this one and we're talking about what
influencers don't talk about
my name is heather torres and you are
listening to the think media podcast
welcome to this podcast if you are brand
new and for all of our returning
listeners i'm so grateful you're making
this tuesday ritual
happen thanks for being here and
listening well like i said today we are
jumping into a spicy topic we are
talking about
image and impact and sean's going for it
he really
dives into you know the rawness of being
an influencer
and what it can feel like and how our
images
our image is projected on social media
and kind of the pitfalls of being an
influencer
i hope you take notes on this one and at
the end of this episode we're going to
recap
some of the reflective questions that
sean's asking in this interview
also at the end i'll let you know about
one of our free
master classes that we have up for you
right now on demand
but i'll get into more of those details
after the episode get your ears ready
because we're heading into today's
featured content
[Music]
so how do you stand out in a crowded
marketplace
how do you create a personal brand that
everybody talks about where
positive word of mouth spreads about you
and how can you experience continual
growth in your business and your youtube
channel well in this episode we're
talking about
three commitments successful youtube
creators and entrepreneurs
make that create unstoppable growth
we're also going to be talking about the
opposites of these
that will stop your growth that will
cause you to be
stuck or even if you've had a lot of
success maybe you're on a plateau
we're going to talk about how to bust
through that but i want to open with a
couple headlines
that i've read from a couple different
articles and blogs
here's the first one influencers caught
out
posing in fake private jet
jets for travel photos right have you
ever heard this it's a real thing
so they caught people in fact there's a
service
that is designed to make to look like
the interior of a private jet
that you hire and so that you can show
off your jet setting lifestyle without
actually
having to be on a private jet
this kind of i don't know what this says
about culture or influencer culture
but i don't feel like it's a positive
vibe like the fact that people are
actually paying for this they're also
posting it all the way on social media
they're not telling
anyone and there was some influencers
people were outraged they're like what
you're faking you're jet-setting
lifestyle but here's another one
teens are deleting instagrams almost
as fast as they are posting them here's
part of the article
my generation is getting so much better
at managing who we are online
said bree ford a 16 year old in
harrisburg pennsylvania
they have there have been times when
i've been
frustrated with something and i'll post
about it and then i don't want it up
anymore so i delete it
no one needs to see that if i'm going to
get over it in an hour
and a new study found that over a third
of young girls
have deleted pictures of themselves
online because they did not get enough
likes man what does that say we're
posting
fake jet photos there's services that'll
let you do that
meanwhile we have young girls that are
deleting photos as soon as they post
them if they don't get enough likes
and that are becoming experts in
managing
their personal brand now of course we
believe in personal branding
but i think there might be a dark side
to some of this if the next generation
is becoming their own pr company for
just what they're posting on
instagram and twitter and tick tock but
here's one more headline i want you to
hear
why are so many people still buying
fake social media followers have you
ever bought so
fake social media followers or ever
bought youtube subscribers
here's the article would you be shocked
to learn that
half of justin bieber and lady gaga's
fans
are fake and more importantly would you
even care
for the mass vast majority of us the
answer is no the number of people and
brands buying fake social media
followers is growing
paying for followers is a widespread act
and while purchasing followers is
against most social networks terms of
use
it is legal to do so and thousands of
accounts
are doing it what do all these stories
have
in common this kind of obsession
with image right this obsession with
how we look online but maybe not who we
really
are online this obsession with how we're
appearing to other people and if we're
getting approval from other people and
applause from other people
rather than maybe making a difference in
the lives of
others we're doing fake jet photos we're
deleting photos off instagram because
we're insecure if we don't get the
feedback that we thought
we're buying fake social media followers
to just boost our numbers for what
for just perception but is there any
real substance
there so what if instead of faking it
until we make it
we committed to personal growth to
getting real experience from the
grueling hard work
of being in the trenches and sh and
slowly developing
our skills i want to just talk about
three commitments successful youtube
creators and entrepreneurs make that
create unstoppable growth
that really speak to this kind of dark
side
of social media and youtube culture
i'm not condemning this culture how how
could we we'd be hypocritical to be
doing that right we're here on the think
media podcast listen
we want you to build a powerful personal
brand we want you to build a powerful
image
online we want you to get as many
subscribers as possible but i really
believe that these
truths will help you go about it the
right way and not fall into these
traps that actually keep many creators
stuck and the first one is this we make
a commitment
to impact over image
it is important that we make a conscious
decision that
impact is more important than image
here's a question for you are you
focused more on
impacting people or curating
your image now i'm not here on the other
side of this microphone and camera if
you're on the youtube channel with the
think media podcast
from some pedestal preaching down at you
these are experiences i've personally
had where if i'm honest
there's been a lot of times where i'm
way more obsessed with my image than
what difference i'm making in the lives
of people how do i look online
oh how did i look in that picture are my
clothes cool are they new
what do people think about me what are
people saying about me
my obsession isn't necessarily am i
changing lives or impacting people
there's times when i'm just trying to
curate my image
how about this question are you more
interested in the appearance of winning
or actually winning a lot of people
are more interested in just the
appearance of being able to have
a private jet you know taking them
somewhere
then actually building a business that
would make it practical for you to fly
on a private jet here's a question are
you more
worried about how you appear to your
peers
and competitors than you are with
helping
your community like who are you fighting
for
are you just trying to like i'm just
trying to look better than my
competitors
in my niche and in my industry i'm
trying to just
outshine my peers i'm focusing more on
my peers than
on the viewers or my audience or my
students
have you fallen in which one do you fall
into and listen
if you make a legitimate positive impact
in other people's lives
the result will actually be you will
have more than enough followers more
than enough customers and more than
enough
income what am i saying it's impact over
image
i'm not saying image doesn't matter i'm
not saying you shouldn't do a photo
shoot like
do an awesome photo shoot work with a
great photographer learn some great
photography skills
learn your color palette wear your
makeup like do that thing
but just what are the priorities and if
our highest priority
this will grow your youtube channel is
to make a positive
impact in other people's lives and we're
more concerned with that than we are
with our image
the result we will always have more than
enough followers we'll have more than
enough customers
we'll have enough money rather than
thinking about buying followers
what if we thought about impacting a few
so that our followers multiply because
we're making
a legitimate impact now i read a book
called story brand really great book
will always link up resources
and they they have an incredible insight
for really marketers and business owners
but i think
every single personal brand and youtube
creator needs to know this
and they say this they say that the goal
of many leaders
is to get people to think more highly
about the leader
image like that's the leader is like how
can i look good how can i sound good how
am i gonna sound
image but the goal of a great leader
is to help people think more highly of
themselves and in the book story brand
what they reveal is they ask you this
question
business owner they ask you this
question youtube creator
is your who's the hero
of the business you're building who's
the hero of the youtube channel you're
building
most answer well i'm the hero this
youtube channel is about me man
i'm the freaking hero dog that's what it
is man
and storybrand would argue donald miller
no
the customer is the hero the viewer is
the hero
and when you get your brand right and
your business right
your customer your viewer your audience
on youtube is luke skywalker
he needs to destroy the death star and
you
are the guide your obi-wan kenobi you
come alongside
to help luke accomplish his
mission man that's real impact i mean
now we all know obi-wan
is is the bomb.com and i mean obi-wan is
cool as well obi-wan's but he's not the
hero of the story
this is a major mindset shift this is
when we shift to
the impact we're making is just greater
than our image
i don't need to be the hero i want to
make you the hero
of the story does that challenge you can
you imagine
if we focused more on making our viewers
the hero
if we helped our viewers win on youtube
and it was less about us looking good
and it was more about
them looking good you know the mission
of an unstoppable business
is to make the customer look good and to
make the customer
feel good even if you have an
entertainment channel your mission
and obsession is to make the viewer feel
something and feel good is it all about
you
or is it all about them question
are you cool with just buying followers
or do you want to actually earn the
followers from hard work and creating
valuable content
and and i get it listen if you've bought
followers or subscribers like
that's not really the point like almost
everybody has at some point in their
journey because they maybe thought it
was a good idea or thought it was legit
or whatever by the way it's not
our advice is there's just no reason to
do it they're bot accounts they'll hurt
the algorithm
it's not an effective thing but again
you know they're fake even if other
people don't know they're fake which by
the way other people know they're fake
because the engagement it's all obvious
the engagement's not there but
what about the confidence that comes
from the hard work
of actually creating valuable content to
grow one subscriber at a time one real
person
at a time it's about impact over image
are you more concerned with your next
photo shoot make your website look good
hiring a pr company so to get the press
logos on your website
inflating your subscriber count even
getting a silver play button
even you know uh even getting a gold
play button
i'm not saying that stuff isn't cool and
doesn't matter but i've even had
conversations with people that like
yeah my next goal is to get a silver
play button what if
and that's a great goal but what if your
next goal
was to help the amount of people you
need between here in the silver play
button
do you see you'll end up accomplishing
both goals but your obsession
will actually be that it's impact first
image second
and imagine if instead of worrying about
your next photo shoot
or trying to like make yourself look
successful on social
your obsession with was to collect
stories
of customer success comments
of change lives comments of people being
inspired helped problem solved
impact over image couple things before
point number two
you know image is easy you might be like
no it's actually hard to get the colors
right and and like my last photographer
you know or whatever no but like think
about it image is easy like going and
taking a photo shoot is a lot easier
than actually changing someone's life
so by committing to making an impact
it's the hard thing to do but it pushes
you to grow because you might say shoot
i gotta level up so i can climb to the
top of the mountain
to capture the precious resources so i
can share them with my community
making an impact and committing to
impact pushes you to level up
it pushes you to keep learning and
studying it pushes you to get stronger
so that you can help your community
with personal breakthroughs attention
business coach
okay youtube creator life coach
social media expert youtube expert i
have a message for you you cannot lead
people where you have never been
yourself
and you cannot impart to people which
you do not possess
yourself now you might say you might be
faking it and doing all right for a
while
like you barely put your toes in the
game and then quickly created a course
listen i want you to create a course but
i want you to be creating
educational content out of the fact
you've been there
and it wasn't and this happens way too
much in our industry and i don't mean to
like
kick the beehive but there's a lot of
business coaches life coaches social
media experts and youtube experts
that are leading people somewhere
they've never really been and the only
reason
they have subscribers is teaching other
people how to get subscribers
sean that's kind of meta that's what you
guys do yeah but before i ever did it
before think media was think media as it
was today i was on my personal brand i
was helping other people get subscribers
i made six figures in affiliate
marketing around tech and even before
that
high five figures talking about gift
ideas and other niches why because
personally
i just wanted my impact to be bigger
than my image number two
the first one is make a commitment to
make your impact
greater than your image number two make
a commitment to make
service content and not selfish content
this is like another point of view of
really kind of the same thing
but i want to tell you a story so i
wrote a book with my friend benji travis
have you read it's called youtube
secrets
and he actually was in new york city
visiting gary vaynerchuk
at vaynermedia and so this was back a
little
two years ago or so and uh the book had
dropped
and he's in the office with gary and he
said gary what's your number one piece
of advice
for new youtube creators and he said
here's what i see he said
i see that most people are making
selfish content he goes you wanted to go
to hawaii
you wanted to go to disneyland and film
your life you wanted to
be getting the accolades and getting
subscribers you want to work with brands
you want
which is true and we're not saying those
things are bad he's just saying it's all
about you
you're thinking about yourself
first you're not thinking about the
viewer or making content that'll serve
people
you're making selfish content and the
priority
is not service you know another example
of this to me
is this whole idea of mission over money
you know some people say that money is
the root of all evil that's not true
it's the love of money
it's when money becomes our first
priority that's called
greed and that means we start doing
wrong things even evil things
even things taken to the extreme that
end up hurting people and not helping
people
but money is not evil it's just not the
first priority
you need money as a tool to accomplish
your mission
so it's just mission first and money
follows
zig ziglar put it this way you can have
everything in your life that you want if
you will just help other people get what
they want
are you making service content or are
you making
selfish content again the secret
is if you want some stuff everything in
the world you want
just help other people get what they
want
first just lead with service
first so answer these questions like who
are you called to serve
and who is it that you help it is my
conviction
that these truths are so needed in
influencer culture
influencer culture i love it it's the
culture we live in
but i also see a lot of danger with i
see a lot of danger for the next
generation
being kind of born into influencer
culture and
sometimes we could just look like
curmudgeons from the sidelines
and criticize ah all the influences just
about themselves it's all about me me me
everybody you know even the attitudes
you sometimes hear brands
get emails that say can i please get a
free hotel room because i have these
instagram followers which is not
necessarily a bad thing to ask
but it's just the word is entitlement
that sometimes there's entitlement on
this influencer generation or whatever
but here's the thing
i don't we don't want to condemn the the
the influence or generation we don't
want to curse the darkness
we want to light a match and simply say
listen
just serve people first
you can have everything in the life that
you want if you'll just help other
people get what they want
first so who are you called to serve no
matter
even if you have a vlog channel right if
you're like well i don't really have
like a business where i answer a
question
no matter what your niche is who are you
called to serve
who do you help do you help them relax
do you help them
escape do you help them learn something
what problem do you solve
and what ambitions are you helping
people reach
winston churchill said it like this we
make a living by what we get but we make
a life by what we give
wow hey friend if you
want to bust out of the plateau you feel
stuck in right now become obsessed with
serving other people if you feel like
you're not even getting lift off with
your
brand maybe just obsess over
impact and don't worry as much about
your image sean are you saying don't do
a cover image and like have a
good brand palette and don't actually
you know go out with my sister and do a
photo shoot
not saying that at all i'm saying
priority number one
serve others priority number one be
obsessed with making an
impact on the end user and when gary vee
was breaking it down
from his office in vaynermedia he just
said do you think about the viewer first
or don't you if you obsess about the
viewer first
you're going to have a great career on
youtube and you'll continue
to bust through growth plateaus finally
number three
make a commitment to improving your
performance
over the applause that you get
performance
over applause there's a book by dan
sullivan called the laws of lifetime
growth it's all about how to overcome
plateaus in life in business
and ensure continual growth and there's
multiple laws i highly recommend the
book and again
we always have resources in the show
notes wherever you consume the think
media podcast
both story brand and this book i think
are huge
for busting through growth plateaus but
this particular law is stated like this
always make your performance greater
than your applause
and he encourages us to make this
commitment he wrote
if you become more skillful and useful
you will receive greater applause
from an expanding audience so
listen i know we want the applause we
want the silver play button i want more
likes i want comments i want views
the number one question people have how
do i get more views on youtube number
two question
how do i get more subscribers on youtube
number three question how do i make
money on youtube
again i think these are fantastic
ambitions that's what we're here to help
you with
and if you become skillful and useful
and put out good content
you will receive greater applause from
an ever
expanding audience however and he goes
on
the problem is that the applause can be
intoxicating
and the temptation can be to begin to
organize your life
around other people's recognition and
praise
so you keep repeating what you did
yesterday instead of moving on to
something new
better and different are you stuck in a
rut
are your views going down are you
feeling entitled like your youtube
channel you're like well i was getting
great views
last year and now i'm posting the same
videos
and my views are going down like why are
my views going down
imagine if we asked it from the
perspective of as my content in a rut
have i actually fought am i focusing
more on the applause
the views then on my performance getting
better
creating something new going back into
the trenches
going back into the gym to work out your
youtube content creation muscles
cracking open a book turning on an audio
book
getting stronger for the next situation
figuring out how you could be different
reinventing yourself for the next season
connecting with your community and
asking deep questions
so you can understand what they want to
see so you evolve your content
getting back into caring about each and
every individual and subscriber and
trying to make personal connections with
them to get those insights
going live for 12 people just to get
feedback
and getting answering their questions
shooting out an email to whatever email
list size
you have and say how can i serve you
what's your biggest pain points what do
you need from me
posting on social media to get some
feedback so that you can
innovate your content to be new to be
better
and to be different see
you just gotta make your performance
greater than your applause
right john wooden said it this way the
famous basketball coach
he said you can't let praise or
criticism get to you
it's a weakness to get caught up in
either one
what does this mean to me this means
that a lot of times and this is very
personal by the way so many of these
episodes
they come out of my own journey where
i'm struggling and i'm i'm worried about
the applause
i'm like uh what but like i got a
negative comments like i'm seeing
criticism or or the praise i used
to get more acknowledgement and
recognition from my peers or from people
they just haven't said anything in a
while am i doing a good job
all these like thoughts swirling in my
head but he's saying
don't let the praise or the criticism
get to you don't let the applause
or the booze get to you whether people
are clapping
uh and shouting you down and giving you
applause or whether they're like boo
you either way he said it's a weakness
to get caught up in either one
that's interesting because sometimes we
might think oh well the praise is good
that's affirmation that i'm doing things
well maybe maybe or maybe it's actually
a distraction that's made you
comfortable
and you are not continuing to grow
because you have
organized your life around other
people's recognition
and praise and i got you stuck in a rut
and i learned this that listening to
feedback is important
like i'm not saying completely shut your
ears because
literally comments might be pointing you
like hey
you were very out of touch in that last
video and you were so like you need to
actually have that feedback
like listening to feedback reading
comments listening to
even criticism can be helpful but check
this out
listening to freedom is listening to
feedback is important
but feeding off it will make you sick
wow applause can be dangerous
it's nice to get some affirmation when
you've put in some hard work
but what dan sullivan taught us in the
laws of lifetime growth
is that our obsession and our commitment
should just be to our performance and if
the applause comes cool
and if the applause is delayed which it
is and your applause
if you're in the sacrifice and startup
season the applause
does not come for a long time you need
to be willing to not need the applause
to determine whether or not you're going
to keep building you got to build
regardless of what other people are
saying come on noah in the ark
right you got to have a vision and know
that you've got a calling
and that you've got an arc to build and
whether people are pumped
criticizing jeering whether they
understand it or not you're building
something
and sometimes the rain doesn't come for
years
it's not about the applause it's about
your performance
and if you feed off of praise or
criticism man it can make you sick
i've been there and i need good friends
in my life to speak truth into me and to
get me refocused
sean it's about the impact dude it's
about your performance man get back in
the trenches
start sharpening this axe start
sharpening the saw keep working on your
craft
and then remember that the applause
is a byproduct i thank god for the
applause we've received
the external affirmation of the hard
work we've put in
but man and this is a trap i see friends
that have had some past success and
their current focus
is just trying to maintain the applause
as opposed to getting back
into the trenches to sharpen to sharpen
their craft
so what's your commitment here when you
commit to performance you're committing
to innovation
and the evolution of your craft eric
reese put it this way
who's a startup expert he said the only
way to win is to learn faster than
anyone else
and that's that commitment to like man i
got to keep learning i got to keep
growing
what i'm working is working today for
what i'm doing youtube my craft my
business my service my coaching my
course
it's working today but i got to stay in
this and i just always got to make my
performance greater than my applause
and listen when he says the only way to
win is to learn faster than anyone else
this isn't about beating your
competition only it's about
serving and impacting people and adding
more value to the people you serve
if you haven't identified your career as
this see i know that i'm an infopreneur
i know that i'm in a career of thought
leadership
that i am compensated for my ideas that
i'm compensated for
teaching and frameworks and writing
books and creating videos
and educating people that's my industry
i know that that's what i'm doing
therefore whether i feel like it or not
it is imperative for me to learn
faster not just to beat the competition
and stay relevant
but in service of others so i mean
i'm i built my life around also things
i'm passionate about
but there's a win-win because when i did
dive deep into books
and keep studying and keep going to
conferences and keep investing in
masterminds and keep investing in myself
and keep leveling up that passes
that information breakthroughs personal
breakthroughs and i keep experimenting
and not just consuming information
but doing tests and staying in the trash
trenches and posting videos and not just
being in the classroom but actually
being
out there creating content then i
ultimately
that trickles down to making more impact
as opposed to
i don't take notes anymore dude i don't
i don't i don't read books anymore i'm
good now
i think media is successful dude like
it's just time to chill now i mean we
made it
nah we didn't make it we never will make
it
we're not playing a finite game we're
playing an infinite game and so we're
making our
performance just greater than our
applause and thank god for the applause
and celebrate your gold play button and
your silver play button
and appreciate when people are thankful
don't get weird about it someone
compliments you and you're like
don't it's i don't want like that's not
what i'm saying listen
as we land the plane it's as simple as
just
making three commitments i'm going to
make a commitment today and i want to
challenge you to make this commitment
with you
with me this is our vision at think
media we want you to be as influential
as you possibly could be
we want you we want you to be large and
in charge listen we want you to be
famous
like see these things are these things
don't make us insecure
our value system is just where they are
in the totem pole
of priority so will you make a
commitment
to impact others as a greater commitment
than worrying about your image
can you commit with me that we're going
to make our cer service
content and not selfish content and
prioritize that serving others is the
priority
over our own needs because you can have
everything in life you want if you will
help other people just get what they
want
and can we make a commitment to get back
into the gym working out our youtube
content creation muscles
muscles and our online business muscles
and our online marketing muscles
because we're obsessed that our
performance is just more important than
the applause
we're not organizing our life around
people's recognition and praise
we're just organizing our life around
the calling and the mission and the
purpose that we have
realizing that the image and
the applause and the money and the
acolyte
accolades they're the byproducts they're
not the main thing
and imagine a community of influencers
that got obsessed with helping others
win imagine
and picture a world where our first
priority was to serve others and make a
meaningful impact in their lives
and imagine the business and legacy and
youtube channel
you will build by prioritizing
performance over applause i can see it
it's the commitment we're gonna make
today and i believe you're gonna
continue to crash through
plateaus dead ends
and stuck areas in the growth of your
youtube channel
when you make these your commitments
you'll experience
unstoppable growth well that was
a powerful episode sean really got into
it didn't he
on that and i wanted to go through some
of the questions that he asked at the
end
imagine if we got obsessed with helping
other people
what does that look like if they're
winning and you're sharing their
successes over and over and over
do you have success stories to share of
the people that you've helped versus
just
always talking about your own successes
picture a world where our first priority
was to serve others and to make a
meaningful impact
in their lives i hope you feel that here
on the think media podcast and
think in general that we really are here
because
we put you first we are all about your
success we say we are
obsessed with your success because we
know that
we're like a ripple effect you know when
you throw a rock
into water and that ripple starts to
happen
well think media we're just the rock
we're just throwing it in we're just
disrupting that water
but you're the ripples and we know that
the impact that can happen in the world
the good that can happen in the world
the amount of lives that can be changed
from the content that
you have and the think community has
that's gonna be
what makes a major impact and so we're
here for you
for that and then last imagine the
business
the legacy a youtube channel that you
were that you will build
by prioritizing your performance over
applause
this was something for me that i'm so
passionate about
not only just helping people in general
but really helping women understand
because a lot of us have grown up to be
people pleasers i mean if we're gonna
get real and honest at the end of this
episode that's who i was
i lived for the applause i wanted to be
the best at the thing
because of the reaction i could get from
others and
when i started to look further beyond
myself really when i started having
babies and i was thinking about
the legacy that i want to leave for my
children
it went beyond just what can i do but it
really went into
how can i help others how can i build
something that's going to impact
others how can i do something learn a
skill that i can
teach others to do i hope that this
episode brings you some clarity
in your mission and in your vision for
your youtube channel
and don't worry we're going to get back
to youtube tactics and tips
but this is why we have the think media
podcast we have it because we want to go
deeper in conversations like this
where maybe it's just sean giving an
exhortation on
this type of a thing or maybe it's an
interview or maybe it's
behind the scenes of something that
we've done in the past that we want to
bring to you
we go deeper in conversations here on
the think media podcast and i hope you
appreciate it
and from some of the reviews that i've
been reading on apple
podcast i'm seeing that you do love this
this review today is from love the
circus and they said
awesome ideas love this podcast i'm
still learning youtube
and in one podcast episode you gave me
many ideas and helped me come up with
content for
holidays i am going to do the free
master class
and put it to good use well thank you so
much love the circus for leaving that
review
and if you're new here and you've not
left a review yet i want to encourage
you to go
over and let us know what episode you
loved or
how this podcast had has impacted you
you know when you leave those reviews it
actually helps other people know if this
podcast is right for them so
leave the details about the things that
you're learning or how this podcast has
influenced
your youtube channel and i love how you
said you're going to put that master
class to use we have a free
master class on demand for you right now
where we're breaking down the three
secrets to success on
youtube sean shares a little back story
about how he was able to
go full time as a content creator and
really start to create that vision
to create the impact that we want to
have on other people's lives
and at the end of that master class we
give you the opportunity to go deeper
with us here at think media
well if you've not taken that master
class you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com to register for
that on demand
class and i hope that that gives you
a ton of value to grow your youtube
channel
thank you so much for being a part of
our think community means the world to
me that you would spend this
tuesday or wednesday or thursday or
friday whatever day you're listening to
this podcast but if you're a tuesday
ritual
goer thank you so much for listening
when it comes out
and i hope you share this with a friend
maybe there's someone in your life who
is getting into this space
and you just want to give them kind of
the pre-warning of what could happen
as they grow in their influence we so
appreciate you and we'll catch you in
the next episode
bye not growing on youtube learn the
newest strategies for getting views and
the best proven ways to make money
at grow with video live a two-day
virtual conference
and you can get your tickets today at
growwithvideolive.com
you